. The United States has now fully vaccinated
about eight percent of the population.
Texas has fully vaccinated just under seven
percent of the population. So, of course,
Republican Texas Governor Greg Abbott has decided
to open everything wide open and the mask mandates
and let her rip. To quote
Anthony Fauci from last year,
Governor Abbott tweeting about this
yesterday, saying, quote, I just announced,
Texas is open 100 percent everything. I
also ended the statewide mask mandate.
He at the briefing made this announcement much
the same way to applause. Take a look at this.
So today, I'm issuing a new executive order that
rescinds most of the earlier executive orders
effective next Wednesday. All businesses of
any type are allowed to open 100 percent.
That includes any type of entity in Texas.
Also, I am ending the statewide mandate now.
Did federal health officials suggest this
be done? No, they did not. Federal health
officials said the opposite. They said do not
ease restrictions quite yet. Not enough people
are vaccinated. The case reductions are sort of
leveling off. This is not the time to do that.
But Greg, Greg Abbott doesn't care and maybe, I
mean, at this point, maybe return to smoking in
restaurants as well. Right. If the argument here
is freedom from Texas Governor Greg Abbott. Now,
I have a few thoughts on this big picture.
This is completely an incredibly premature
it's completely irresponsible. It makes no sense
to do that. Being said, one element of this
is I wonder how much it will actually
change people's behavior in Texas, because
all along you had lots of people
in Texas ignoring the guidelines
and the people who are paying attention
to the CDC and Fauci and the White House
are probably not going to change what they're
doing because of Greg Abbott's announcement. So
there is a real question as to how much this
will actually change in Texas. It will change
some things. I wonder how much. That being said,
I can understand and sympathize with the urgency
of getting businesses open for the sake of
business or at least wanting to. The mask mandate
seems like just utter virtue. Signaling to
the anti mask crowd wearing a mask is so easy
you could open the businesses fully, but keep the
mask mandate and make it all safer. So the mask
mandate ending seems to me far more political than
it is even economic. But it is Texas and that's
clearly a big part of what they're doing. The next
question is whether this is destined to backfire.
What I mean by that is, is it too early? Of course
it is. Is it against the medical recommendations?
Is it against public health recommendations, what
Texas is doing? Of course, there are enough people
vaccinated where there's a mathematical case to
be made for doing this. No, no chance in hell. But
Texas has the benefit of it being warm in
much of the state we know about. The storm's
warm in much of the state getting warmer as
we approach spring just three weeks away.
The virus is, generally speaking, on a downturn
and vaccinations are increasing. So as boneheaded
as this decision is by Gov. Greg Abbott, there is
a chance that they may merely, by odds, get away
with this without as big of a disaster as we might
imagine, assuming that vaccination continues. And,
of course, the people most at risk who understand
the virus are probably going to keep being safe
anyway. So the case increases that this will
likely lead to in Texas, probably are going to
come mostly from younger people who behave less
safely and will be vaccinated later. But that
might not be affecting hospitalizations too much,
since young people are unlikely to end up in the
hospital if they get sick now, some will some old
folks will get sick and die because of this. Some
random young people will, too. But overall, Texas
has twenty nine million people. Statistically,
this is an irresponsible early decision to be
making, but they might by chance get away with
it without as big a disaster as this would
have been if they had done it. For example,
in October of twenty twenty, this is the governor
making it official. Remember that the mask mandate
wasn't enforced in many parts of Texas anyway.
People were already dining indoors. So it's
quite possible that in some general sense, Greg
Abbott is going to be able to come out of this
vindicated. And I use that term very loosely,
thanks to the fact that a lot of the guidelines,
the numbers in Texas already reflect a lot of
guidelines being ignored anyway. And vaccination
in warmer weather is only going to help. That
being said, doing this right before spring break,
there's going to be some chaos. And other states
clearly are starting to go in this direction
of Mississippi, announcing yesterday almost at the
exact same time they are lifting business capacity
limits. They are lifting their mask mandate.
And I predict there will be more states to come.
It strikes me as premature. It seems to me the
more cautiously optimistic timeline would be,
let's go really hard the next
60 to 90 days on vaccination.
And we could have, for many aspects, aspects
of the population in much of the country,
a close to normal summer. Maybe a lot of states
doing this will prevent us from having that,
I don't know, but that's the news out of Texas.
Let me know if you live in Texas, will you
change your behavior as a result of this?
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman,